[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Sean is
with us in Atlanta hi Kean how are you
I'm good how you doing better than I
deserve what's
up well just yesterday my father asked
me to help him buy a house um mind you
my father's 61 I live with him um old
are you really I am
whoa yeah
why are you living with your
dad well right now at this moment well
during Co um I found a mentor who taught
me a skill digital markeet online and I
managed to turn it into a career I make
$86,000 and I sat down with my parents
when it's first when I first got my
first job and told them my ambitions and
what I wanted to do and they were
finally me just staying home as long as
I paid uh the light bill and when they
said yes I was like it's three years ago
what do you make
I make $86,000 why are you living at
home you make
$86,000 I plan on moving out this year
good like yesterday yeah yeah you make
$86,000 I know go have a life so what's
this got to now you live on your own and
you're 22 and you have a career making
$86,000 because we just moved you out
now we've got that settled now your dad
wants you your help buying a house but
you don't live there so why does he want
your help buying a house cuz he can't
buy it on his
own no my dad
um my dad all his wife they've been
living Check to Check he's like he's um
just for give you more context he's it's
like $600 but he pays $1,000 in car
payments he pays $1,000 in car payments
yes between two cars that that's why
he's living paycheck to paycheck okay
keep
going
and um
so with all that and the things that
he's told me in passing I feel like what
he wants to do would actually hurt him
yeah more so I agree and it's just I
don't know how to from from the
financial things and things that I've
learned consuming you know your content
and other content sh I feel like home
ownership is like not like a like a real
thing currently for him I don't know how
to well if he's asking he's not asking
you for financial advice he's asking you
to sign on the line to help him get a
deal now let's change this okay let's
talk about this for a second because
there's two
different emotional situations with your
dad emotional situation number one is
you live there emotional Situation
Number Two is you don't live there which
is what I'm recommending yeah because
once you move out the obligation that
you feel you don't have any obligation
it goes away then you're sitting down
with your dad and going dad I love you
um but I I I can't can't participate in
you buying a home because I love you I
think you're going to bring harm to
yourself until you get your financials
cleaned up and I can show you some of
the stuff I'm learning if you want me to
if you don't want me to and it'll help
you get your house but if you don't want
me to I understand and but I can't help
I can't participate in you buying a
house because I think it's going to
bring you harm and I love you and I
don't want to bring you
harm okay that's it's a lot harder to
say when you live there mhm hey is he
going to be pissed when you tell him
that you don't want to sign oh yeah for
the loan definitely I don't I personally
don't think he's very prideful I don't
think he's gonna be pissed at all like
from what he's told me that he has saved
like from all the years that he's worked
he's I he do I know for a fact he
doesn't have the cash for a down payment
yeah and I'm afraid that he's gonna make
a stupid decision to pull from his
retirement yeah and he he might and he's
well and he's got a he's got a car
payment that he's get he needs to get
rid of that he needs to build an
emergency fund he needs to save a down
payment whether you're 26 or whether
you're 66 those same things apply and
that's what I would tell him and I'm
almost his age I'm actually older than
him so um you know I would say young
man well the thing you have to accept is
even if you frame it the way Dave so
eloquently put it even if you come to
him you say all those things he still
might go and do something stupid and
it's likely with the way he's been
living life and his age it's likely that
he will continue on that same path and
if he doesn't you've just got to and
hear this it's not your fault no his
behavior is not because of
you okay okay you you helping him do
something stupid or him doing something
stupid on his
own is that you know he does something
stupid on his own is not your fault you
helping him do something stupid that's
bad for him is your fault and you've
identified that that you know what that
is but it's very difficult for for you
to tell your dad who is 40 years older
than you
no it's emotionally hard to do that it's
doubly hard to do that when you live
there right dude when you move out in
your proximity to all this changes
you'll be shocked at how little you
think about this but right now right
under your nose you know how he it
changes the level of obligation yeah you
have an obligation an emotional
obligation toxic though it be to help
your dad okay you have a a double
obligation to help your dad if you live
in his house right you follow
me both of those obligations do not bind
you to doing something that harms him
and we're all three in agreement that
this is harmful to
him yeah buying a house when you're
broke Kean is not good for you it causes
you to get broker that's why we call
them
Brokers That's it man I mean you've
heard me say that a thousand times and
so I want your dad to get a house but I
don't want his house to get him and I
sure as crud don't want it to get him
and his newly successful young
son I'm so proud of where you are and I
don't want you to get chopped down as
you're in a growth spurt
yeah this is going to chop you down
young man don't let it do that and and
your dad doesn't mean to do that but he
doesn't know any different and he's just
flailing around and he thinks buying a
house is going to make everything better
and it's not it's going to make
everything worse for him and if you get
involved it's going to make everything
worse for you and you want a roll you
need to rock and roll and go get you a
place like this
week this week man go get you an
apartment this week and set you up a
life and get yourself strong and then if
you've got a big old huge pile of money
and you got a million dollars and your
dad is 82 and he never changed his ways
and he still broke and he can't buy
groceries you can afford to buy him
groceries Dave I feel like there's been
a theme all three hours of parents
parents just messing up it's parents
stealing money from their kids it's
parents taking out Credit in their kids'
names it's parents wanting them to
co-sign whether I cosign on that loan
with you or the kids co-signing on the
loan with them it's just parents parents
misbehaving parents yeah so if you guys
want to label this particular episode
for YouTube It's called misbehaving
parents yes what happens when parents
misbehave well let me tell you you screw
your kids you do that's what happens
when parents misbehave and they put they
have go your job in life should be to do
the opposite of screw your own
kids it's just it's sad the energy that
they have to put in to unravel all of
this whether it's having to call credit
card agencies or you know call the bank
or call the police and say no it wasn't
me that spent the money it was my dad or
no it was my mom it's unfair a criminal
stole because stealing someone's
identity is fraud fraud it's a federal
fraud if you do it with credit cards
it's fraud and if it was anyone else
criminal fraud it's a crook if someone
does it in Russia and they seal your
identity we go oh the Russian mafia is a
bunch of crooks if your own dad does it
you go well I'm paying it back cuz my
daddy stole my identity no your dad is a
freaking criminal he's a crook you need
to follow a police report on it ain't
that crazy how we'll let our own family
treat us and you wouldn't dare ever let
somebody on the street treat you that
way okay I know that's right it was
anyone else behaving parents misbehaving
parents behaving parents